they're becoming more common
in two separate incidents hours apart
armed people enter banks demanding their
own money
lebanon is in crisis for three years
people haven't been able to access their
savings because of informal capital
controls
sally hafiz is among them armed with a
handgun she was accompanied by activists
who threatened bank employees before she
was given thirteen thousand dollars from
her account
in this country this is the only way to
get our money back we didn't steal this
money we worked hard to earn it
sally says she needs the money to pay
for her sister's cancer treatment in a
similar incident last month an armed man
named bassam sheikh hassan held hostages
at a bank for nearly 10 hours before
receiving part of his trapped savings he
too said he needed money to pay for his
father's hospital bill
many others like sally and bassam who
are facing strict limits on withdrawals
of foreign currency gathered outside the
bank after the incident
we are ruled by thieves who are forcing
us to use violence protesters chanted
people are losing patience the economic
collapse is in its third year the
currency has crashed unemployment is
high and government services are nearly
non-existent
people believe politicians and bankers
are protecting themselves while they are
suffering as a result of the financial
crisis bank deposits were used to fund
the state and cover deficits now the
state is nearly bankrupt total losses
amount to more than 70 billion dollars
there is a lack of political will to
agree on an economic recovery plan that
would distribute losses and as the
crisis worsens depositors warn they will
have no choice but to take their money
by force senator al jazeera beirut